a giant team rallied together for this
first hackathon project and built a
prototype of a wheelchair that could be
driven with the eyes and what happens
with ALS is that eventually people will
progress to the point where they will
loose control over the muscles that
allow them to move or speak or breathe
but very very often they retain good
control over their eyes and so we can
use that anything that you can still
move we can use right if you can move it
we can make a switch out of it that's
our motto you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it I'm your host Gretchen Hughes
Inga
[Music]
and Paradiso is an interaction designer
and the principle user experience
designer for the next enable group at
Microsoft Research
she's also the epitome of a phrase she
often uses to describe other people a
force of nature
together with the diverse array of team
members and collaborators many of whom
have ALS or other conditions that affect
mobility and speech and works on new
interaction paradigms for assistive
technologies helping to make a more
bespoke approach to technology solutions
accessible at scale to the people who
need it most
on today's podcast and tells us all
about life in the extreme constraint
design Lane explains what appalls is and
tells us some incredibly entertaining
stories about how the eye tracking
technology behind the eye controlled
wheelchair and the hands-free music
project has made its way from
Microsoft's campus to some surprising
events around the country including
South by Southwest and Mardi Gras that
and much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
and parody so welcome to the podcast
thank you for having me you're an
interaction designer and a principal
user experience designer at Microsoft
Research we're absolutely gonna get to
how you came here a bit later cuz it's a
great story but to get us going here
tell me what gets you up in the morning
well I love my job and I love the people
that I work with and what gets me up in
the morning is coming in and
collaborating with my team and my
collaborators on some of my other teams
and getting to work on something that I
have a personal and meaningful
connection to I love the people that I
collaborate with the people who inspire
me every day the people living with ALS
and other disabilities and I feel very
blessed that I get to do that for my job
how would you describe the work that you
guys are tackling what kinds of
questions are you asking what kinds of
problems are you trying to solve I would
describe the work that we're tackling as
extreme constraint design we solve hard
problems for people dealing with extreme
constraints that are the result of
disability and everything about what we
do is constrained in some way everything
from being able to communicate directly
with our user base and our collaborators
to dealing with things like resourcing
and funding and time the essence of what
I call extreme constraint design is that
freedom can be found in very very hard
constraints it seems counterintuitive
because you think you want to have all
of these options and all of these
choices but constraints can be a forcing
function and they can cause you to solve
problems in unconventional ways that you
wouldn't normally think of on a linear
path but a lot of the problems we're
trying to solve can't be solved with a
conventional linear path you have to use
unconventional methods intuition and
creative problem-solving and you have to
have the resolve and the tenacity to be
able to overcome some of the setbacks
that come with such a constrained
that leads really beautifully into the
next thread which is among your
professional interests that you have
listed in your bio you include new
interaction paradigms in assistive
technology and we're gonna get much more
deeply into the assistive part of this
in a second but it begs the question
what's wrong with the old paradigm I
mean why are they left wanting well the
old paradigms work for a lot of people
and there's nothing wrong with paradigms
that are already working the problem is
for the people that we work with and
that we collaborate with there aren't
any existing paradigms for them and the
ones that do exist don't take the whole
picture into account what we've learned
working with the ALS community and some
of the people with similar disabilities
other motor neuron disabilities even
spinal cord injuries or people who have
other speech and motor impairment from
disability is that a lot of times there
isn't a one-size-fits-all solution for
somebody our disease space that we
started with for example ALS has so much
variation in onset and progression mm
people lose the ability to move their
muscles in their body but that happens
in different ways and in different
patterns
somebody might lose speech first
somebody might lose hand strength first
or leg strength first so it's very hard
to come up with a sort of
one-size-fits-all path for them and also
I think technology is continuing to
evolve for example we've had eye
tracking technology around for decades
right but it hasn't been available at
scale and in a way that we can prototype
and experiment on now you can get an eye
tracker for a couple of hundred bucks
you can plug it into a surface device
use Windows I control which is something
amazing that has come out of our team
that was led by Harish Kulkarni one of
my beloved colleagues and we can do
things now that would have been very
very expensive and purely academic maybe
even five years ago 10 years ago so what
we really want to focus on is helping
people in the now to two year time frame
so part of it is that part of it is that
stuff just hasn't been invented yet or
if it has been invented it might have
been invented by a graduate student in a
very small way just to show a proof of
concept but it isn't something that
could actually be used by somebody who
needs it or support it or sustained and
so we have to get creative I know that
ALS or amyotrophic lateral sclerosis has
been a motivating driver for some of the
projects you're working on and people
with this disease are literally as you
say locked in their bodies and normal
interfaces don't work for them so you've
disrupted these interfaces and come up
with some remarkable new technologies
and one of them is a project you worked
on with team Gleason
I don't assume that our listeners will
know what that project is but tell us
about this project that you've done with
team Gleason well the way that we first
got connected with the ALS community was
through Steve Gleason Steve Gleason is
it's an understatement to say that Steve
Gleason is a force of nature he was a
professional football player for the New
Orleans Saints he's a massive celebrity
in New Orleans and he's been living with
ALS since he was in his 30s Steve had a
professional relationship with Microsoft
and when we had our first hackathon he
wrote a letter and he stated what he
wanted Microsoft to work on in terms of
his technology he's saying you know hey
I'm using your technology and here's
some opportunities for improvement and
he had great vision around this I want
to be able to move my wheelchair
independently I want to be able to argue
with my wife some of the rumors have it
he wants to be able to win arguments
with his wife which is an lol because
she's also a force of nature but he
wanted to be able to meaningfully
interact with his wife and he wanted to
play with his son and raise his son he
wanted to be a father and a husband and
a community member he wanted the things
that everybody wants and a giant team
rallied together for this first
hackathon project and built a prototype
of a wheelchair that could be driven
with the eyes and what happens was ALS
is that eventually people will progress
to the point where they will loose
control over the muscles that allow them
to move or speak or breathe but very
very often they retain good control over
their
and so we can use that anything that you
can still move we can use right if you
can move it we can make a switch out of
it that's our motto so anyway this team
got together and they won the hackathon
and they were able to as a result of
that sit down with Saachi I think they
got an hour with him to talk about where
they could potentially take it and
around that time next was forming the
organization that I work in and a guy
called Jay Bevers went to Peter Lee who
is the corporate vice president and
leader of next and he said I want to
take this project and make it for real
because at the time Steve hadn't been
able to drive it it was a proof of
concept it wasn't made for real and he
said I want to make this for real and
Peter funded the team and so we said
about taking that early prototype and
making it real for Steve in fact Jay and
I went down there and took the very
first wheelchair components to him and I
was out in the yard playing with Steve
son and Jay was collaborating with Steve
and they were working on it and working
on it we didn't know if it was going to
work didn't know if it's gonna work and
Jay says come in here and I come in and
Steve's got this big grin on his face
and he's driving he's driving himself
around and it was just this great moment
so over time Jay and the team and I
worked with Steve and Steve tested the
wheelchair you know used it beta tested
it and we continued to refine it to the
point where he can use it successfully
in fact I was just at Mardi Gras and I
was fortunate enough to be in the team
Gleason crew and Steve I drove almost
the entire parade route by himself and
you know watching that in action and
watching him using our technology was a
career highlight for me you know the
other thing that we worked with team
Gleason on was working out some of our
communication based technology the very
first thing that I noticed when we went
down to visit Steve was we're sitting
across from him as you would like yes
you and I are and he's using his eyes to
type out his words and there's a pause
and it continues and it continues and we
don't know what's going on and you know
we kind of get up and
look around or call for caregiver and oh
you know he needs to recalibrate or he
needs assistance and we have no way of
knowing that the other option to that is
standing over his shoulder and watching
him type without being able to make eye
contact it's not how humans communicate
so every time we came home from a trip
or from a pals visit or from any of our
collaborative exercises we would sit
down and have a debriefing session and
we would start to brainstorm and we came
home and I was talking to John Campbell
one of the engineers on my team saying
you know we need some kind of a status
indicator we need some way for people to
know hey I'm typing or I'm calibrating
or wait a minute I'm about to speak
because that was the other thing that
would happen is we speak so much more
rapidly and we take this for granted
then somebody can get words out with
their eyes right so you're looking at
maybe five to 20 words a minute
depending on the accuracy and skill of
the eye typer so what happens is the
conversation moves on more rapidly than
the person who's using their eyes to
type is able to get their thoughts out
and it creates disruptions in the flow
of conversation and you can see the
effect of that on the person using their
eyes to type and so we were thinking you
know how could you have somebody quickly
in a conversation without having to type
things out when one of our interns at
the time who's now a full-time engineer
here Alex via naka started to work on
that exact problem and he started
looking at ways we could have
conversation partners assist with typing
speeds or ways that you could set your
communication preferences maybe save via
your mobile device ahead of time my eyes
go up for yes and I blink for no those
are my gestures so if you can ask me yes
or no questions you know that will help
facilitate the conversation or you know
one of the other things that he came up
with was quick reactions we had a
keyboard that we've been prototyping and
working with Steve on working with
several of our pals on and we added
these quick reactions to it where he
could without having to type anything
out have a laugh or a sigh or a groan or
some way that you can be in the
conversation more naturally and we
learned that from Steve because he was
doing these things he already
intuitively understood that and was
coming up with these strategies
and we would watch him use those and he
would have a bunch of you know sort of
messages or lead-ins or natural sounding
communication segues he would have those
stored and we watched him have these
remarkably natural communications that
maybe some other people who hadn't been
doing it as long had it mastered yet and
so we took those observations and just
directly translated that into features
in our keyboard that's absolutely I mean
what it makes me think those three
little dots that kind of yes circulate
and you're texting you know some they're
typing and they're typing something
along I'll wait or an emoji that can say
yes with one picture right is that kind
of exactly what came out of those early
discussions we had an early prototype of
this device that we called the arc
reactor because it looked like the arc
reactor the Ironman used because you
know we're nerds and we're proud of that
and it was a prototype device and we had
some other interns come in and study it
and from this early work all of our work
around expressivity and communications
was born and a whole bunch of great
outcomes came out of that but what
happened is we took that arc reactor and
we wanted to extend it beyond status and
it was exactly what you said with the
three status that's was we had this
round LED display that would basically
function as that you can take a lot of
cues from text messaging apps because
that levels the playing field a lot so
we took a lot of inspiration from that
and then we extended that we wanted to
be able to express emojis again from
text messaging you know this is
something that everybody knows how to do
and that is a common paradigm that
people understand is part of our social
communication now so at the time we
didn't have the resolution in that
device to be able to create the emojis
for real you had to be able to write
code there was no preview environment so
it was a great proof of concept but it
wasn't tangible yet so Gavin Genki who's
one of my favorite collaborators and my
former boss on the advanced development
team in Microsoft research labs came up
with this amazing authoring environment
and you can open up this environment in
Windows you can create basically
anything you want to
in it you can take an animated gif from
the internet you can drop it in and it
will pixelate that and turn that into an
emoji and he worked hard on the hardware
what he did was he wrote all the
firmware he created an entirely new
device and it had the resolution that we
needed to be able to show those
expressive emojis and things like that
which we then used off-label to use a
pharmaceutical term for our hands-free
music project to give a visual
affordance to each individual drum which
we'll talk about but yeah so this is
sort of the nature of the nonlinear path
of innovation here Gavin just jumped in
because he thought it was an interesting
space and so that was the birth of
expressive pixels and it was all from
wanting to enhance expressivity between
somebody living with ALS and their
families or their communities well you
know the other thing that I'm thinking
of is when your watch sort of remote
interviews on TV and the person's got a
headset yes and there's that gap we all
have that uncomfortable fill in the gap
thing and so what I hear you saying is
that it's trying to make it more
immediate and natural that gap is one of
the key drivers and we have noticed this
in almost every interaction we've either
participated in or witnessed is that
people in modern life are severely
uncomfortable with silence discomfort is
always a great driver for growth and
that discomfort was an amazing driver
for innovation and technology you keep
referring to pals yes tell us what that
is I know it's a thing it's not just
your guest buddy
so it's both it's one of those
delightful acronyms that also means
exactly what it sounds like pals is the
acronym that the ALS community uses for
people living with ALS and cowls is an
extension of that and that is usually a
caregiver living with ALS when I'm
referring to a pals and you hear that
subject-verb disagreement it's
technically just me using the acronym
for people living with ALS
[Music]
at heart
humans are not just survival machines
we're expressive creative beings for
whom literature art and music fill our
souls and disabilities don't make us any
less human so tell us about the project
you've worked on to empower differently
abled humans to participate or continue
to participate in creative expression
particularly the hands-free music
project the hands-free music project is
very near and dear to my heart for
exactly the reason you stated for me
personally music has been such an
important influence in my life and so
what happened is early on in the process
several people had been sitting in a
room having a conversation people
experts from all over Microsoft it
wasn't just Microsoft research but
having a conversation about how to
design this keyboard and I remember
asking has anyone here actually spent
time with people living with ALS using a
keyboard or not and one woman who had
been a speech-language pathologist had I
don't think anybody else in the room had
so we had a bunch of really smart people
trying to solve a problem that they did
not understand and so the first thing
that you do as a user experience
designer is you have to go and
understand your user base so that you
fully understand the challenges and how
to solve certain problems we had had a
meeting early on and it was a guy called
Mike Elliot who is chief neurologist at
Swedish hospital at the time he was
running the ALS clinic at Virginia Mason
and a woman another force of nature
called Annie Ike Myer and she was the
care service director of the ALS
evergreen chapter which is the local
wing of the ALS Association which is the
National Organization and the local
chapters sole purpose is to support the
ALS community they had heard about the
hackathon and had come in and asked how
can we be involved and I said you know
we really need to find some local pals
that would be interested in spending
some time with us do you have any way
that we could start to meet people and
they were all over it
dr. Elliott said please come to clinical
rounds and we will find some people that
might be willing to let you sit in on
their doctor's appointments and sure
enough they found us a couple of people
and so we got to know them and found out
a lot about them personally how they use
technology where they're struggling you
know what do they love doing and a lot
of people had a strong relationship with
music one guy he was in band and he was
pretty progressed at that time another
guy was a music teacher I met two or
three drummers I could feel how
important that music was to people and
that other forms of expression some
people enjoyed painting some people were
writers but they really lit up when they
were talking about things that came out
of that creative well in them right and
so I couldn't stop thinking about that
and I came back and started talking to
the team and this is one of the many
things I love about the Enable team
people are coming up quickly with ideas
and how do we solve this and we started
kicking ideas around and some people
were saying you know no we just can't do
this
the timing problem is too hard and I'm
thinking well what's the alternative you
don't have access to creative expression
no that can't be possible so we started
to talk to different people and a lot of
people were actually interested in the
space and we created a small sort of
virtual team the timing was great on it
because things were aligning we had the
right group of people at the right time
to work on an early prototype we had
also consulted with Steve Gleason he had
given us some great ideas on a looping
based mechanism he showed us one of his
favorite artists who goes on stage and
she plays different instruments and
records them creates a loop and then
layers on top and then puts her vocals
on top and we thought well we can
certainly do this and it sort of started
to come together and this fantastic
researcher was visiting from UC Boulder
his name is Shawn Kane and he said I've
got an idea on how we might be able to
do this I need some equipment but I
think we can make this
work proof of concept how we could
enable somebody to play the drums or
percussion with their eyes but we really
wanted to do this for Jeremy best Jeremy
best is the guy that I was telling you
about that I had met at clinical rounds
and I went back after our rounds and I
was chatting with Annie egg Meier and
saying you know what does the deal with
this guy and they're like oh my gosh we
love him he's amazing he was a high
school teacher for twenty years so I
went and I found his band on VanCamp
downloaded their CDs started to listen
we passed it around and we started
talking about how we might bring Jeremy
back to his music we didn't know if we
were going to be able to pull it off so
we didn't tell him right away
so we had the drum kit it was a kids
drum kit we had it under a sheet so it
was like just this ridiculous lump in
the middle of the table and they roll
Jeremy in and he's looking at the lump
and he's got to go through you know
research survey questions and do some
speed tests and you know he's doing a
bunch of stuff that is really important
stuff that we needed for other projects
but you could see he kept on looking
over there and finally we finished the
work part and so we take the sheet off
the drums Sean starts to explain you
know what we're doing and does he want
to try this and Jeremy uses his speech
device to type out yeah you might have
to beat that out but that's what he said
so we calibrate him we bring it in again
we don't know if it's gonna work or not
we're all standing around like please
let it work and he just starts ripping
on the drums and he's got this huge
smile on his face and it was just this
great moment and then what happened on
top of it is arturo toledo who's one of
our designers on our team and arturo is
also a DJ and he had some of his
equipment in and he starts riffing on
top of Jeremy's rhythms and they have
this moment where they're looking at
each other and he had commute you could
feel it and it was at that moment where
we were like we're gonna keep on working
on this this is definitely something
that's worth investing in and that's how
that project got started so and that's a
story that actually makes me cry as I
listen to it because I get that you know
it's that's what musicians
live for is that in rowing they call it
swing where you're all together you feel
like you're one unit absolutely
this story has another little chapter
involving South by Southwest the music
festival well it's a tech festival a
music festival a movie festival it's all
that now tell us the story of how the
hands-free music project ended up at
South by Southwest and what happened
once it got there so picking up where we
left off
where we had shown the proof of concept
to Jeremy and we became energized by it
and decided that was validating enough
to keep the work going we were trying to
figure out how can we put some cycles on
this because we had other things that we
were working or working on windows I
control we're working on research and
several other priorities how could we
keep this going and so what end up
happening is I decided to hire an intern
to come in and collaborate directly with
Jeremy on hands-free music and I came
across this candidate named Paul
bachelor and I knew from the second I
Skyped with him that he was the one so
you know we were talking and he had
ideas already and I had said you know I
don't have a lot of direction for you
but what I need you to do is work
directly with this collaborator that we
have and see what you guys can come up
with the goal is to get him to play
music again and he was a Berklee College
of Music undergrad and he had gone to
Stanford to their Karma program which is
computational music program and I
remember asking him you know so you're a
musician but you're scientist you know
how do you balance that and he said well
I identify first as a musician second as
a scientist and that was the other
criteria was we wanted somebody who was
a musician who would be able to think
musically about this and not just
computationally about this so what end
up happening is he created this great
interface based on a clip launcher which
is a interface that's used sometimes in
professional music composition software
Ableton Live for example has a clip
launcher and so he wanted to take
paradigms that musicians knew and
understood and used those instead of
creating a brand new paradigm but he
used them in different ways
a project ended up being called sound
jam so Paul was here for the summer he
created an interface a novel I gaze
enabled interface that had sort of four
quadrants on it and one quadrant was
riffs one was melody one was percussion
and the other was sort of whatever we
wanted to put in could be harmonies
could be effects or whatever and it was
all generated on the fly this was not
created out of recorded WAV samples or
anything he had done all this
computationally and so you could pick it
up pretty quickly and start playing some
music and then he could lay effects over
it using your eyes and he found really
interesting and novel explorations of
the space and in parallel we were
building on what is now called sound
machine which was codenamed D music for
Duane lamb who is the lead engineer on
that project and that came out of that
early work that Shawn Kane and Arturo
Toledo and the team had done and so we
were working on sound jam in parallel so
we had two different explorations going
at the same time and I don't know what
made me think of this but I had said you
guys all right we're gonna wanted to
create a forcing function or a target
for people you know we're going to apply
to South by Southwest if we get this
prototype up and working and we can get
it released because that was one of the
criteria will apply to South by
Southwest and at the time I was also
thinking maybe Jeremy could play South
by Southwest that was ambitious you know
and we didn't know where we were gonna
land it and I was like and I'll take you
all had no idea how I would do this
frankly because I didn't think hey I
wasn't even sure we'd get it done then I
didn't think we'd actually get it we had
to pull a lot off just to get the
submission in right and I really wanted
to get the submission in we had to
create a submission video and we had a
full-size drum kit built by the team
including not just the enable team with
Chuck Needham arena spiridonova Gavin
Genki from the advanced development team
who were important collaborators as well
so everybody pulled together to get this
prototype going and we brought Jeremy in
to play it and Henry filmed it for us
and it was I think the day the
submission was due we had to get this
done we didn't even know if we were
gonna get it working
everything was coming down to the wire
we got the whole submission done like
three minutes before the deadline in
fact several of us had stayed late to
finish it and we served collapse on the
floor and we were just like if that's
all that happens that is enough like we
released Sound Jam open source that was
important to us we got the very first
bits for Sound Machine released so we
were able to exercise our shipping
muscle we were able to get expressive
pixels hooked in because we wanted a way
to see visually what was happening on
the drums and so we were able to get
that all hooked up and working I'm it
just was crazy that we were able to get
it to pull together and so then we
submitted to the Innovation Awards in
two categories they were supposed to
notify us I think in December and the
time came and went and we never heard
anything so I just assumed you know I
got to give the speech of you know we
didn't get in but it's really not the
point you know and so I think it was
January at this time I get this note
from South by Southwest saying you know
if you don't accept your nominations
tomorrow we have to give them to
somebody else we had gotten into both
categories how did you not know that so
I get a lot of email and my inbox has
its own event horizon just like a black
hole and I had been checking and what
happened is my clutter algorithm had
grabbed it and put it into the clutter
folder well it was bad and really bad
algorithm that thing is usually helpful
except for when it's not so we scramble
accept the nomination and then we have
to get a trip planned we have to get
funding to get the whole team going and
you know Rico Mel var who is our leader
and just a wonderful human being yes he
and Jamie riff Lee who's our business
manager made it happen and we got it so
that everybody who had worked on the
drum kit got to go and we're trying to
get Jeremy there and in the end we were
not able to pull that off and so what we
decided was you will be there but you're
just gonna be there digitally and so one
of the things that they require you to
do at this event
is to create an acceptance speech a
tweet length acceptance speech in case
you win and you had to make a video as
well so we had engineers and designers
pulling the video together everybody
rolled up their sleeves jumped in and
worked on things Chris O'Dowd who is our
chief hardware guy and builder of
everything built a t-shirt cannon that
could be launched with the eyes I mean
we had all kinds of cool stuff and we
went down there and I was giving them
the speech the whole time it doesn't
matter if we win that's not important
what's important is now we have more
people who might be able to work in this
space that are gonna see it so we go to
South by Southwest and so then you know
we win we win the thing and we can't
even believe it we win in the music and
audio innovation category and we really
didn't think we would we had no idea and
so we have Jeremy on bass time he's got
a speech prepared we have Sean Kane who
was I would talked about earlier on my
phone and we all go up on the stage it's
supposed to be this tweet length
acceptance speech and we put Jeremy up
and so they can see him he starts out by
saying hi I'm Jeremy best coming at you
from my living room in Seattle with
female synthetic voice he's already just
his expression and his opening he's
already got everyone right right and
then he says this is so much better than
public speaking I'm not even wearing
pants
everybody cracks up then he goes on to
deliver this gorgeous speech which was
not tweet length and the guy who had
handed out the awards was crying people
in the audience are crying we realized
as we're on stage that although everyone
can see Jeremy we hadn't reversed his
camera so he's basically looking at the
top of Chuck's head same with Sean so
thank Corrales we finished the speech
everybody else who went overtime got the
music and got kicked off the stage
except for Jeremy and so we were able to
experience that with him and at the time
we didn't want to over represent what we
had you know they think they wanted to
tell this story like oh he's playing
music again because of this and and that
wasn't true we wanted to stay focused so
that we could get there but technology
think this sort of stuff takes time it
takes way longer than you think
so we focused the next year we just
kept on going to Jeremy's and we kept on
working on it and we finally got to a
point where he had created his first
composition and it was just a great
moment and so we have so much more to do
with that but we've already found other
applications that we can do now
[Music]
and it's about this time in the podcast
where I asked researchers the famous
what keeps you up at night question and
I do it because I want to know how
researchers are facing and addressing
the idea of consequences intended and
otherwise that come with all these new
technologies so given the scope of what
you're doing and the world that you're
doing it in with the enable team is
there anything that keeps you up at
night
absolutely what keeps me up at night is
knowing we don't yet have a cure for ALS
I've seen the suffering that ALS causes
and the impact it has on families and is
profoundly unfair and I've also seen
firsthand the effect that technology can
have restoring people's purpose in life
whether it's a creative purpose or
whether it's raising your children or
whether it's working or doing your taxes
or buying a car these are all things
that our collaborators wanted to be able
to do after ALS had taken their speech
and their movement we have this
technology that we know can help and we
still have a barrier connecting that
technology to the people who need it
we've made great strides with Windows I
control again Harish kil Kearney and the
windows input team have put so much
heart into this and that's the first
step but there's so much more that needs
to happen and that keeps me up we
started with a pals program of 10
collaborators and nine of them have
passed away since we've been working
with them people that we love that we've
become very close with and that keeps me
up at night and it will continue to keep
me up until either there's a cure for
ALS or we find a way to continue this
work and to take it to scale where we
really need to take it not just in the
United States but outside of the United
States where people have even fewer
resources and less access so that keeps
me up and I love stories with an
unconventional twist there's so much
more interesting stories in that you're
part of a relatively small group of
researchers here
I'm sorry that didn't arrive with a PhD
in a suitcase and your education path
isn't necessarily what people would have
thought hey this woman is gonna run the
joint on user experience designed for
enable at Microsoft Research how did you
get here I feel like it was it was an
alternate path and you're right as my
friend James McCann says I did not go to
the 25th grade I had an unconventional
upbringing I struggled a lot in my early
years I was just dysregulated in general
and I didn't have some of the skills
that I have now what I did have was
champions
I had champions every single step of the
way I was in my Community College which
was really my only choice after you know
that flaming high school career Keeler
yeah
spectacular high school performance and
I was struggling there too I had been
living on my own I had other issues that
I was dealing with and I was sitting in
my philosophy class one day and my
philosophy teacher Blair Morrissey I
still remember his name asked me stay
after class and he asked me do you want
to go on with your education yes I do he
put me in touch with a Dean we created a
plan I started to take things more
seriously and become accountable to
myself and then I went away to
university and I did fine there I did
great there so I got it together I got
it together late but I got it together I
was an English major that was something
that I just loved and I started my
career as an editor and my husband and I
wanted to move out west and we kind of
came out to Seattle with two dogs and no
jobs we didn't know anyone I start
looking for work and so on a whim I
applied for a technical writing position
at Microsoft and I got there and I
didn't actually know what I was
interviewing for my interview was nine
hours long I didn't understand it and I
called this woman that I knew who worked
at Microsoft and I said I think it was
terrible like it was nine hours long and
she said no it went well you went all
the way through and right around the
same time I had interviewed for a
startup it was during the big startup
common and I had gotten an offer there
and I took that job
was a PM job and I worked at that job
for 11 months and then that whole
company just tanked with most of the
other startups and we all got brought
into a room they said we're done we
don't have any more money
everyone's laid off we all go to the bar
and I called their Microsoft recruiter a
couple days later she said you know why
don't you come back in and just meet the
new director you don't have to go
through a new loop or anything just come
meet this group and I did and I was a
technical writer for three weeks and
they reorg and then I became basically a
web producer and worked in the office
group for four years and there was a
position available in Microsoft Research
for a website manager and I came in
started that way and we built a new web
platform and you know that was fun and
interesting work I built up a team I
started managing designers and then when
we ship that platform I started to have
opportunities to work on interesting and
cool research projects and that was so
great and I knew I was like this is what
I want to do and I got to work on some
of the best projects I got to work on
micro productivity with Jamie TVN and I
got to work on Pocket skills with Mary
Shore Winsky and I just got to really
stretch and I found the research work so
much more interesting and that was just
a great fit for me and so I did that I
worked on the advanced development team
for 11 years and loved it and would have
probably never left had not this
opportunity I was seeking a more
meaningful connection and I was talking
with Peter Lee who was just forming next
and he mentioned this team is forming
around people with disabilities and you
can work directly with the users and
that was it for me I said that's what I
want to do as we close and what advice
or words of wisdom could you give the
next generation of researchers who might
be interested in making interaction
design and user experiences for anyone
and everyone better I would say first
and foremost follow your gut be honest
with yourself learn from your mistakes
be fearless and care about something
deeply and if you find something that
you care about deeply stay with that
things tend to work out that way they
really do and you know there are
opportunities
in tech for people that do come from
unconventional or non-traditional
backgrounds and there's great
interesting meaty work there's great
problem-solving multimodal interaction
is such a cool and interesting space and
there's so much room for invention there
so stay with that figure out what your
North Star is and stay focused on that
at the expense of all things and
everything else will become noise and
that is also what will give you the
strength and the resilience you need to
overcome the setbacks because this kind
of work comes with a lot of setbacks and
you have to fight a lot of battles so
yeah be a bulldog and Paradiso thank you
for coming in today it's been awesome oh
gosh it's been my pleasure thank you so
much for having me to learn more about
Ann Paradiso and how researchers are
bringing innovative interaction design
to people with disabilities visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]